boeing is trying to get back on track
after a major blow to its space plans
the company is trying to get ahead of
competitors in the race to launch
American astronauts into space but on
Friday Boeing botched the first critical
test for a Starliner space capsule and
now the mission could face significant
delays Hillary Lane is here with more on
what happened and what's next Hillary
good morning good morning the new star
liner is currently in the wrong orbit
after an error through the capsule off
its original course since the launch
nASA has canceled the spacecraft's
original mission and is instead focusing
on returning it to Earth in the best
possible condition Dolly's engine at
full thrust a successful launch from
Cape Canaveral we've cleared the tower
the Atlas 5 rocket lit up the sky as it
climbed into space attached to it Boeing
Starliner astronaut capsule an automated
spacecraft headed to the International
Space Station with supplies and holiday
gifts engine operating parameters
continue to look good
the star liner was slated to begin
carrying live astronauts next year but
problems following Friday's launch
brought those plans to a sudden halt and
the orbital insertion burn has been
delayed a glitch in the star liners
control system during the test caused it
to burn significant amounts of fuel
preventing it from gaining enough
altitude to rendezvous with the space
station if we would have had crew in
there number one they would have been
safe to be very clear our crew would
have been safe NASA and Boeing claim the
issue occurred 31 minutes into the
flight star liners launch was a
milestone test for Boeing the company is
competing with Elon Musk's SpaceX to
develop space taxis capable of carrying
astronauts to the space station
these are passionate people who are
committing a big chunk of their lives to
put Americans back in space from our
soil NASA pay nearly 7 billion dollars
to both companies in 2014 but technical
and financial setbacks have placed both
more than two years behind schedule in
March
SpaceX carried out a successful unmanned
flight of its crew
dragon capsule to the space station but
in April the company faced a major
setback when that same capsule was
destroyed during a ground test the
Starliner is expected to land in New
Mexico on Sunday had the tests been
successful it would have set the stage
for Boeing to begin man launch tests in
2020 those plans could potentially be
delayed several months Jeff okay Hillary
thank you very much
you